hello I recently finished my biggest
project yet a whole animated tour of the
history of writing but before we move on
I wanted to take some time to cover two
things one what we missed and two what
we got wrong
but I think there's someone better for
this job the narrator herself hi I'm
Jessica hopefully you already know me as
the voice of thoughts pill if you
haven't had a chance to catch that yet I
highly recommend it there's a lot of
great stuff in there
I'm also the girl who's about to start
showing you how your life is made of
code over at compchomp but a thought
spill yeah this was really a labor of
love
and as it stands now we put about 10 to
15 minutes into this film for every
single person that's watched it so far
so it's a very personal connection for
us 99% of that is Josh he did all the
art the animation the music scripts for
the animated history of writing even
recorded himself narrating the whole
thing over and over and over again but
he ended up liking my version better and
so yeah I'm the narrator um one thing
that that meant was that there were a
lot of parts where you actually hear the
like languages that we're talking about
and I don't actually speak those
languages so we ended up cutting that
but let's talk about what else we didn't
get to so in the beginning we had
prehistory and the cave rushes over so
much of history and speculation about
proto-writing we kind of used it as a
metaphor just as much as an actual
historical place and when you leave the
ancestral cave and enter the civilized
world we meet logographs the original
plans had a span from the dark cave up
to the well lit world above once we're
up in those cities we profile a handful
of them some of them like the Minoans in
crete just barely get old mentioned
later on in the series and if you start
digging it's not hard to find other
early scripts that we skipped altogether
like elamite or Cypriot or Zapotec and
the questionable unsolved mysteries of
prehistoric writing like Vinci symbols
and into scripts and whatnot integrating
those really started to sidetrack the
story so after going down the birth of
writing hit list we ran into that
tension between meaning and sounds well
we originally had a second tension for
these cradles of civilization
what is writing for these symbols help
civilizations expand carve propaganda
track their goods
time after time these old logo graphs
are about kind of boring mundane things
like counting goats in barley or that
king so-and-so ruled for such-and-such a
long time and smoked all of his enemies
throughout his many many days of being
awesome but unfortunately for the
Romantic in all of us some writers were
capable of turning even these early
symbols into verbal art the most famous
early example is Gilgamesh a story that
topped the cuneiform bestseller list for
over a thousand years which is really
impressive we ended up folding the idea
behind this tension into the flexibility
and creativity versus consistency
tension that shows up when we talk about
the Maya script it was particularly sad
for us to cut Gilgamesh it's a story
that reminds us that civilization and
its innovations tame the savage human
but at a cost
nature is wild immortality is elusive
but civilized humans can live on through
their physical achievements during their
lifetimes it was sort of an uncanny
prism forth Alice's warning in the
introduction oral ideas are embedded but
thought spill the technology of writing
D embeds U and offers some degree of
immortality to your thoughts and actions
ok onto rebus writing we talked a lot
about taking a character and using it
for it sound like value of course
there's another option beyond using the
same character for smaller or larger
chunks and this will apply to later
innovations to the character can change
in the process anyone who's ever learned
to read another writing system has the
experience of painfully copying every
little nook cranny and Seidler of a
symbol before finding out which strokes
are meaningful and which ones can be
left out ad serifs to an eye and you're
fine believed the dot off the top and
things kind of get weird unless it's in
Turkish and then there are entirely
different letters although it's a
crucial step in learning to script like
a native the stroke game is some
that's obvious from the inside but can
really perplex Outsiders I contrasted
using characters for syllables in
cuneiform versus consonants in Egyptian
hieroglyphs two technical details got
cut out here first the writing direction
we later mention when we get to China
that where words go and where they stop
matter and writing we were going to be a
bit more specific for hieroglyphs
showing you that when you're reading
hieroglyphs you read into the bodies
some materials will tell you into the
faces but even when there's no face
around body parts still face against the
direction you're reading fun fact
and for cuneiform we had a whole section
on Josh's favorite cuneiform quark
that's right he's got a favorite those
two mara grams and a kata grams that
evolved as the script was passed around
the Fertile Crescent it didn't really
fit well into the script but it became
its own video and this clip from that
video made its way into the documentary
when we talked about how the early
choice to use syllables shaped every
later version of the script so there was
also an important question to ask here
and when the hits rather close to home
is it surprising or novel that the later
scripts around the Mediterranean you
know the ones that lead to our alphabet
end up using consonant segments like the
Egyptians had already been doing we
didn't ask it on to determinative this
revolved around Chinese and spills over
into the part on Maya but it's really
worth taking some time to read up a bit
on how this happens in other scripts and
how they use determinatives Egyptian and
cuneiform actually use them too
it's one of the reasons each section in
this story is structured around a
specific development in the history of
writing we're looking at these as common
solutions to problems faced by multiple
scripts not just cultural teams the
other reason is we wanted to jump around
with Tzadik locales because traveling is
fun even if it's just in a cartoon
anyhow determinatives I learned
classifiers and determinatives and
radicals together if you're interested
in pulling those concepts apart and
digging deeper I recommend starting with
this paper on the use of complementation
in the Maya script basically it argues
that we should use the term
determinative for a meaning sign that
helps us choose the spell
of a word and classifier for a meeting
sign that tells us which category the
word belongs to another thing when it
comes to China is stroke order the way
of writing the characters Josh actually
thinks this is so important he wants to
write a whole separate script and do a
different video for it I know he
recorded a rant a really long one I
don't know if he's planning on animating
it but if you're interested you might
want to let him know oh yeah both
Chinese and Maya remind us that sound
writing isn't the right way to write the
arrow of history doesn't inevitably
point from meaning to sounds inventing
phonetic characters does not mean that
you abandon your logographs innovations
and traditions can hold hands in a mixed
writing system like this and a lot of
you picked up on that but I wanted to
make sure that we specifically put that
out there so from Central America we
flew to Egypt which reminds me we're
going to stand by this title for now
provocative yes but not misleading oh I
will say one other thing about Egypt by
focusing on the trajectory to our
alphabet we totally missed out on
another thread that was in the initial
story plans from Sogdian to Mongolian I
don't know about you guys but I
personally would love to have seen what
kind of fun crazy characters Josh came
up with for covering Mongolian um
Genghis Khan is one of my favorites
do you just however you want to save the
same ha man came up later to when we
didn't get to tell this story is about
to carrion and ethiop of alpha
syllabaries although at least the album
Gaeta did squeeze in there for one quick
little exercise at the end of India
speaking of alphabets I really like the
way Greece turned out Josh wants you to
know he thinks it's a bit funny that the
Greek is that the Greeks and thought
spill no etic stuff that wasn't common
emic knowledge in ancient times your
newfound friend talks about Troy and the
ancient Greek script that actually
predates the alphabet but he stops short
of calling it linear be truthfully it's
already an anachronism that he knows
about the script in the first place and
can mention how it works since early
documents written in the Greek alphabet
suggests that Greek civilization fell
into complete illiteracy essentially
they all forgot how to write
and that brings us to an interesting
idea that actually didn't make the cut
it's when I mentioned a Josh when he
shared his outline the first time people
losing writing this animation looks at
writing as a series of inventions and
improvements but what about the steps
backwards and sideways and even away
from writing what impact of those have
on writing to get a grasp of the
strangeness here think about the use of
pictures and nonverbal layouts of
information on websites and what other
ways to be supplement or move away from
the written word speaking of alphabets
we brought up the correspondence between
symbols and sounds and then the birth of
the Latin alphabet we originally wanted
to go down the road a bit and discuss
historical spelling English and French
spelling are notorious for this but over
time the alphabetic principle can get a
little wax since a word might be spelled
the way it was when this system started
even when it's pronunciation is
modernized in flagrant disregard for the
ancient tongue the example we plan to
show for this was from Irish and it went
like this
right the word Huah yeah that's right oh
and yeah we totally hear you that we did
not cover uppercase lowercase it's
definitely a topic that we want to go
into but we didn't have time to fit it
into thoughts pill it really is worth a
video of its own okay so onto Ogden's
the papyrus trader was a reminder that
writing back in the day wasn't some guy
grunting and making crude marks there
was already an entire industry behind
each stroke of the pen or pressed the
stylus into clay think of all that it
took to make an ancient Mediterranean
text harvesting to papyrus cutting the
stalks open and cutting it into strips
gluing layers of those strips together
crosswise to make a sheet using
well-developed trade networks to
distribute that paper overseas it goes
on and all the Phoenician merchant was a
mental prick to help remind you of the
obvious that writing liens on the
development of civilizations the
materials resources trade rounds it was
also a way of getting you to think of
the economy of writing and extending
that to get you to ask quest
about how the economy shaped the look
the use and eventually even the
dispersal of writing writing on the
horizontal recto or front of the papyrus
instead of the vertical verso of the
papyrus or how ancient letter shapes
changed from chiseled to inky on the
Mediterranean map we see some scripts
pop up one of them is in Iberia well the
rather unique paleo Iberian scripts are
semi syllabaries derived mainly from
Phoenician with some possible Greek
influence okay time is getting away from
us here I promise I'll just mention a
few more goodies in Phoenicia we tackled
mattress and pointing and originally
asked a bunch of questions for you to
ponder what's better in a writing system
optional extras like vowels added in
only when you really needed that
something straight or a system that
demands clarity even when that clarity
is superfluous hmm let's skip ahead to
King Sejong who's heard exotic tales of
the west of India this was a nod to the
concept of India as the West in East
Asia the most well-known example of this
reference is in the Chinese novel
Journey to the West but if you start
reading you can dig up a whole history
of relationships here's another hint
the Goju one of Japanese kana have an
order strikingly reminiscent to the
layout of Devanagari used to write
Sanskrit yeah okay so in Korea since
feature alphabets get treated as a
separate type of writing system we
thought it was worth including in our
major moments some of you definitely
disagreed Korea is also the location of
our technical error that just stands out
like a sore thumb
Josh switch the name of two of his shape
keys so these Korean characters got
swapped out in the final cut
so after Korea we end with a look back
but our idea of a look ahead at the
future of writing didn't make it what
about changes in how we communicate like
pictograms or signs or relying more on
videos and images to communicate what
about emojis are we communicating better
info faster now so writing is just less
necessary and it's not doing the same
job at once did West Cecil shared a
similar thought in his talk about the
future of language and it's been on our
minds
oh and do different scripts do different
things to our brains
how does growing up with a different
writing system impact anything else like
the way you think about language or
ideas or even the way you store words
finally and josh has been trying to get
me to stay quiet about this but I want
to tease and say that there are a decent
number of Easter eggs scattered around
the world he built I don't know if all
of them showed up in the final camera
angles and whatnot
but a lot of them do
those um so that wraps this up I just
want to thank you guys so much for
taking this journey with us I'm really
glad I got roped into this I was very
hesitant at first I said they're not
going to want to hear a different voice
on the channel but you guys were so
welcoming and your feedback in the
community has just been fantastic if
you're interested in seeing more of me
or learning how your everyday life is
made up of code or hopefully both you
can check out my new channel compchomp
josh is going to be over there animating
making stuff fly around the screen and
coming up with a lot of the cool topics
that we do on that channel as well and
if you have it already and you
definitely should subscribe to native
Lane and encourage Josh to keep doing
videos about language otherwise I'm
going to steal him and he's only going
to be doing computer stuff now I know
he's really busy with classes and has
some other projects but your
encouragement when it's genuine it
really matters and even if you know you
just have him get some quicker sketch
your art out there the videos are fun
anyway subscribe for language and now
subscribe for programming language fun
to chomp
you